et on va tout de suite retrouvé notre
envoyé spécial à kiev du leader crack
bonjour gulliver on le voyait sur ces
images les russes patine autour de kiev
où on est on de cet encerclement de la
capitale ukrainienne
les russes n'ont vraiment pas réussi à
encercler la capitale ukrainienne comme
il avait clairement l'intention au début
de cette invasion il y à un mois ils
n'ont pas plu du tout faire du progrès
dont le sujet de des villes comme vassil
kivu ville attire va qui ont été la
scène de combat n'ont pas été prises par
les russes et les combats se concentrent
toujours au à l'ouest et au nord-ouest
de kiev ce matin dans la capitale depuis
le centre ville on entendait beaucoup
d'explosions de tirs d'artillerie ça
s'est arrêté il est un certain temps
mais on a l'impression qu'il ya eu des
combats intenses autour dire pile
pendant la matinée les ukrainiens 10
d'avoir contre-attaqué et avoir repris
le contrôle d'une bonne partie de cette
ville d'hier pink est une ville dortoir
au nord-ouest de kev mais ce sont des
informations difficiles à confirmer je
pense que plus tôt c'est une bataille
qui continuer avec des cartes et qui
changent de mains assez fréquemment
gulliver vous vous trouvez à aca fin on
le voit sur ces images derrière vous à
quoi ressemble la vie quotidienne dans
la capitale ukrainienne aujourd'hui
alors vous voyez derrière moi la rue
derrière moi ces clashs pratique c'est
l'une des axes centrale de kiev il y a
en temps normal presque constamment des
embouteillages sur cette rue vous voyez
bien qu'il n'y a pas du tout
d'embouteillage il y a quand même des
voitures qui passe constamment
d'une certaine manière je pense que la
vie a repris pour certains habitants de
kep ceux qui ont décidé de ne pas partir
mais beaucoup de commerces je dirais la
plupart restent fermés au fur et à
mesure certains magasins certains cafés
certains restaurant rouvre parce que les
gens se disent il faut continuer quand
même il faut il faut servir les gens qui
sont là mais
loin d'être la majorité le supermarché
fonctionnent les pharmacies aussi merci
beaucoup univers craque pour toutes ces
informations en direct de qui